ukraine's front line may be far from the
shooting range in the capital kiev but
it's never far from the mind of leonard
ostaltsev
a veteran of the conflict in the east of
the country where ukrainian forces are
fighting russian-backed separatists he
fears russia could attack once again
because he doesn't trust vladimir putin
he can do whatever he wants as today
president biden says that it's a
boy with a nuclear weapon without
friends and i agree with him on 100
he's like a
little dictator leonid says people must
learn to protect themselves
the owner of this gun store says that
more and more people are coming in to
buy a weapon worried by the situation
that sales have gone up by 30 to 40
percent in the last two months
in another part of the city a basement
converted into a bomb shelter one of
thousands in kiev that has been reopened
in case the worst happens it was built
during the cold war by the russians who
have now become the enemy
a full-scale invasion would lead to a
third world war in the centre of europe
it wouldn't be only ukraine involved but
all the other countries anxiety here
over russia's military buildup on
ukraine's border is being exacerbated by
moscow's latest move military exercises
in belarus less than 200 kilometers from
kiev but not everyone is worried for
many daily life is a bigger concern than
the kremlin
i don't know i think that russian russia
they mostly like doing these exercises
for the world to have a dialogue with
russia mostly like not to make a war
because they are not interested in it
they're capable of attacking they want
to attack but would they dare would they
really do it nearly eight years of
conflict in ukraine's east have cast a
long shadow but most hope that the
ongoing diplomatic efforts will put a
de-escalation in sight for the latest
crisis natasha butler al jazeera kiev